est ce qu'à fait parler tout le week-end
ça n'est pas novak djokovic babar les
images de l'instant non ce qui a fait
parler tout le week end
c'est
un mystère plutôt une main mystère
[Applaudissements]
oui une main mystère qu'avait son
apparition sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya une personne autour de la table
qui est un ami avec qui on est comme les
cinq doigts de la main avec qui on met
souvent nos mains en crabe
c'est à dire comme ceci qu est cette
personne
ouais m'avait juré qu'ils feraient
fidélité qu'elle aura pour du sexe c'est
à dire entre le ramadan et les kippour
c'est à dire qu'il n'aurait pas de sexe
pendant 100 jours à steene ans
malheureusement qu'il a postées très
beau a été bon quand il est très beau ça
que j'avais pas vu ce monsieur ben
voyons on voit rien c'est quoi ton fils
alors les chéris matthieu delormeau
cette main
tralala c'est un ami c'est autre chose
elle est plus à un temps annoncé à son
oie c'est ça la connaît
tu crois tu arraches et la matu mec
[Applaudissements]
mathieu je ne vous demande rien pour me
dire cyril je ne souhaite pas en parler
et on refermera ce dossier comme on l'a
ouvert bon c'est bien votre chance vous
voulez bien au point de dire si les je
peux dire deux trois mots ou bien pour
me dire cyril je ne peux rien dire ou là
où je peux tout dire de leurs mots
sommes dit le tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne rien dire et prendre deux trois
semaines de vacances derrière de tpm
paix alors cyril concernant plus d'un
le ramasse axe c'est vrai que j'avais
promis fidélité à mon sac de 100 jours
100 jours sans sexe parce que je voulais
je voulais budget explique effectivement
que là que la la la l'énergie sexuelle
devienne une énergie créative et ben ça
c'est par vérifier alors j'ai tenu 86
jours non deux ont un poids de 2 ans
j'avais 12 ans sans coucher mais à quel
âge
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dingue lui ses yeux son petit peu
sont soit votre web mais c'est fou je te
dis à tous ce qui plaît dans les yeux de
gars dans le cerveau bien bravo benjamin
très bonne voire très bonne ramon benji
alors là c'est bien donc 86 jours c'est
bien quand même qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ce cas seront vingt septième jour
c'est bien il ya eu le week end week-end
à rome était ou à marrakech à marrakech
ouais qu'est-ce que je célèbre l'amiable
il n'a pas vu que les bosses du chameau
non alors sachez que cette personne n'a
pas trouvé mes fesses molles voilà mais
ces sept personnes étaient parties avec
toi cette personne va alors je vais pas
en dire trop tôt à la sorte en fait
sinon on n'est pas un groupe d'amis et
c'est un ami dan amis s'étaient déjà un
petit peu chine et voilà et c'est
compliqué pour lui parce que hein
il n'a pas encore vraiment dit son
homosexualité à toute sa famille et 2 il
vit quelque chose qui est très compliqué
sortir avec une star du surcroît
internationale puisque j'étais connu
aussi rares acquis
[Rires]
en fait là qui est des gens qui
attendaient devant l'hôtel à marrakech
et tout ça c'était compliqué pour lui
alors admis donc rappelle mathieu je
peux avoir vire peu ce que je peux vous
dire non mais nous dit nietzsche que ce
que vous pouvez voir la houle trentaine
d'années d'accord très jolie profession
intelligent mains puissantes et on est
en pvc pour le moment d'accord c'est à
dire en prise de contact plus en prise
de contact henri decoux attention parce
que je sais que bien compris que pdc
c'est autre chose
la violence est petit week-end il vous
aime beaucoup
j'ai dû aussi parlé de ça j'ai dû aussi
écarté le dossier nous nord parce que
c'est compliqué tous les week-ends ou
qu'est ce qui se passe avec cyril tu me
fera pas croire qu'un mec qui connaît
mieux le serveur parker tu vas pas mis
la main au cul tête à tête problèmes
comme ça donc je dirais voilà l'histoire
ils sont en devenir et j'ai posté à un
moment de bonheur c'est joli pour ces
conneries c'est beau voilà tout en
restant discret et ben bravo
[Applaudissements]
mais s'il y a des suites et quand est ce
que vous êtes en lob où est-ce que
c'était juste voilà une aventure
non non non c'est un début de quelque
chose dont elle est la hausse on
s'entend bien tu mesures que c'est en
basque est une caméra que tu as l'air
content si je veux là je te la joues mis
les caméras je veux que ça ne change
rien
professionnellement vraiment là vraiment
aucun souci avec ça l'art c'est fait
[Applaudissements]